when you said that there's absolute
truth and i'm not
critiquing absolute truth but to me that
presumes classical logic
it either is true or it isn't and then
there are various forms of classical
logic so how are you
sorry there's not various forms of
classical logic there are various forms
of logic intuitionist para consistent
and so on
so then why did you arrive at that and
then also well
what is it that you believe af if
nothing makes sense that's something
that i struggle with
i'm also wondering how is it that you
avoid this nihilistic
trap of of psychologically
home being homeless or philosophically
being homeless
i'll make those questions succinct so
number one you're using a form of logic
why did you choose that one uh
okay um let me let me uh go back to the
to the
the last one because structure because
i i as i said i look juriad in the
questions
um and when i said nothing makes sense
that
that was not you know about everything
in the world i mean
when you turn on the faucet the water
comes out that makes sense yeah
unless you scrutinize it then you
realize but
this was specifically about you know
what is existence
and uh you know why what what is
existence so you can have one theory
that you know
god is uh is a a
a necessary being and god created the
universe that's one theory
another theory is that the laws the deep
laws of physics whatever they are
uh are cosmogenic um
pick your choice there are lots of
different ones
and all i'm saying is of all those
different categories none of them make
sense
and obviously one is true
and you know that's that's where where i
start now
if when you get into the the classical
bimodal logic or the
uh the tetralemma logic of
of eastern traditions um you know i
can't tell you i'm an expert in the
difference in
in how the tetralemma uh argument of
uh of uh what is it you know p or minus
p
both both both plus v and minus b
and minus playing you know each of those
uh i i i think
my senses is that those terms are in
that form of logic as being used in a
um in in a in a blurry
way and that um you know
at the end of the day the kinds of
questions that we ask
have a a a digital yes no
kind of answer once you define
what that ult what that choice is
take the question is conscious does
consciousness demand
anything beyond the purely physical
world
now you can you can blur that question
by say well what do you mean by
physical and if you have a you know
fifth force of nature or a pan psychist
point of view or
you know does that count as physical or
not physical
or how do you how do you work that out
well that's that's a semantical point
about what you deal but ultimately if
that's the answer
then that answer is uh becomes an
absolute answer however you create that
answer even in a fuzzy manner
so um to
to deal with the question
as i said does god exist or a
traditional god or is there
is consciousness demand anything beyond
the physical
um you know what what does it mean what
would it mean
to have a uh a non-bimodal logic
to those questions so if consciousness
is uh physical
it requires something beyond the
physical
um if that's
either does or doesn't but if you have a
four-fold logic it would it would say
that
it it it um it does and doesn't at the
same time or it doesn't and does
doesn't doesn't and both are wrong
um and and that can give you an insight
into the complexity of these questions
but ultimately there
is there there has to be some kind of an
answer they can't
you you can't if if
if we're defining the physical world and
again you can you can expand your
thinking of what the physical world is
that's another set of issues but if you
restrict it to the physical world and
his consciousness
demanding more of that what would it
mean
to say there's a to use the other two
forms of logic
to that question that means it does and
doesn't at the same time
it it it does require something
non-physical and doesn't require
non-physical
and both are true if that's the case
if that's the case it's hard to conceive
but if that's the case
if it does and doesn't at the same time
the fact that it does i think would
would skew the answer to that it it does
because
it's kind of a possible world analysis
uh this is a technique in philosophy you
may be familiar with and it
it asks what happens in in
every possible world now a possible
world is that an entire state of affairs
so it's not just a world like a planet
or something it's
it's the it's all reality
and a different possible world could be
you know if there are
10 to the 90th particles in the universe
if one particle
is in a slightly different um
polarization
that's a separate world everything else
could be the same so there's an infinite
number of possible worlds
so you ask questions is
something possible is to ask is in any
possible world can that exist
now there's the the this has been used
in what's called the ontological
argument for god's existence
which basically says you know if you can
conceive of a god that is uh
maximally everything uh you know
totally omni uh well i'm represent or
everywhere omnipotent omniscient um
if you can all of those things the
maximum possible god that which there
cannot be anything greater
um could that you don't know where that
god exists but could that
go could that kind of god exist in one
possible world yeah maybe i could
maybe maybe i'd see in a zillion
infinite number of possible worlds maybe
one of them that kind of god could exist
so when you when you admit that and then
you go into that possible world
in that possible world god is all
uh a god it is a necessary being so if
god's
unnecessary being in that one world then
it has to be if it's a necessary being
god has to exist
and so you've gotten into a logical trap
i don't believe the ontological argument
proves god's existence
but very smart philosophers have
difficulty finding out the
the error in the in the argument that i
just made which is the called the modal
ontological argument for god's existence
uh it doesn't work for sure
i mean i don't believe that but it is a
tricky argument so now what that does
is it goes back to the questions we're
asking in a four-fold logic system
if you have a consciousness being
something that is both
fully explained by the physical world
and
not fully explained by the physical
world which contradicts
our twofold logic classical logic that
would seem to indicate
even with that fourfold logic that in
one of those
one possible world consciousness uh
does require something beyond the
physical
and therefore it it would indicate that
it
that if it is true in one possible world
that it is
then then it is a true a truism
even though it may not be in the vast
majority of of worlds
um so i mean that's an argument
that i i would i would at least uh
suggest
that shows that a the four-fold logic
is helpful in in
being able to see deeply into some of
these very hard questions
and i need to learn more about about
that and and
uh and i look forward to to uh to doing
that and when we're dealing with
global philosophy of religion and
eastern traditions and the big questions
of these two big series coming up
um we'll we'll explore that um
and i think those that that uh
complexity of logic
enables a deeper understanding of what
these questions mean
uh but i'm still you know backward
enough or west
to westernized to to think that at the
end of the day
uh it uh it it it is going to alter my
thinking about
the the uh the fact that there is an
answer to these
questions within a twofold logic
classical system